You appreciate the inspiration of good design...
...and you love when the things in your life inspire you.
Introducing the HTC Rhyme.
The phone with an entire set of thoughtfully designed accessories for you.
Simplicity is true luxury.
HTC Rhyme offers a smart, elegant design.
Every detail has been carefully crafted...
...to deliver a unique and seamless experience.
Its exquisite, unibody design is truly different from other phones.
The HTC Rhyme is light, sleek and slender, making the stylish seem effortless.
Keeping with current color trends that draw inspiration from nature,...
...HTC Rhyme adds style and class to your look whether you're dressed up or down.
And HTC Rhyme delivers features that complement your life.
You'll find it a breeze to use.
After all, it is thoughtfully designed to think the way you do.
More than a phone, HTC Rhyme is a total offering that fits your life perfectly.